j'ai sais pas où sont mes bouquins se
marrant à la poubelle je les ai jetés
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont marron et
vieux faisait henry original tes
chaussures oh oui vous aimez c'est ma
femme qui me les a offertes
est ce que tu as vu cette fille qui
fouille dans nos poubelles
si tu la vois tu pourrais pas l'aider
oui c'est promis il torée vue non henry
quoi trop mais le mois mac là je te
promets
soit l'on vous a jamais dit que ça peut
être dangereux de prendre quelqu'un par
surprise quoi faire tout bizarre je
construis un truc
ouais je suis architecte je peux
peut-être vous n'êtes pas l'un de ces
pervers qui aiment toucher les petites
filles pas vrai elle me prend pour un
pervers
les pervers ont des moustaches tout le
monde sait ça monsieur michel on l'a
fini pour aujourd'hui
j'ai mis les voiles aujourd'hui
non non je peux pas je vois ma mère à
midi le diable approche n'était pas la
joie
je me disais que je pourrais peut-être
parler vous allez cramer ma cabane c'est
un accident
vous savez combien de temps ça m'a pris
donc construire un radeau c'est à chier
vous appelle alerte enlèvement j'ai des
plans b sont là si j'ai plein d'idées
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je dois
faire de filer un coup de main
que les choses soient bien claires je le
fais parce qu'on n'a pas le choix et si
vous fouillez dans mes affaires je vous
fait la tronche c'est clair
[Musique]
l'écoutant il j'ai besoin que tu te
concentres et que tu te mets ton travail
qui est cette fille vu l'engouement
s'est tout à coup de main coiffé nous
construisons un radeau à totalement
arrêter avec ça et penny aurait adoré
[Musique]
tu es content on va attendre que la
marée nous les ramène
- elle était elle était un peu sauvage
comme un ouragan
[Musique]
a perdu la tête on a juste un peu perdu
notre chemin
je me suis trompé sur toi comment ça tu
n'es pas un pervers
je suis pas mécontent que ce malentendu
soit enfin dissipé